next and orchestra of students from one
of the world's great science and
engineering universities comes together
for the world premiere of a new piece of
music a tribute to the events of the
Arab Spring meet the composer it feels
like actually the tempo of it slides up
yes the conductor if you end a phrase
with a corner but it up that the hold
its full note value and the student
performers but was really phenomenal the
way he uses different colors and the way
they kind of play off each other I
really really enjoyed it the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
wind ensemble presents awakening
downtown Cairo is a battle zone as tens
and thousands of protesters hit mystery
can remember driving to MIT on my
commute and listening to the radio to
President Hosni Mubarak and hearing the
passion in the voices of the people who
were participating in the Arab Spring if
I could somehow get someone to write a
piece of music that would have our
students have to think about the Arab
Spring movement what it means and get
some historical context as it's
happening right now that was my goal we
are extremely honored to have an MIT
alum back on campus jamshid sharifi hey
everyone Jeffrey Sharifi is a new
york-based composer and producer he's an
artist that is equally comfortable in
the fields of world music in pop music
in composing original music in writing
music for film on I'm digging it it
sounds really good in here too he
graduated from MIT in the mid-1980s and
he directed for a number of years the
MIT festival jazz ensemble so here is
someone who really knows what it's like
to make music at MIT how it feels
you
we think of MIT as one of the world's
great institutions for engineering and
science but in fact the arts and
humanities have been thriving here for
decades and I think it's something
that's been a part of the fabric of MIT
for many many years but it's not as well
known
awakening is at peace for wind ensemble
that I've written on the theme of the
Arab Spring one thing that I tried to
avoid is thinking that I was going to
make any sort of definitive statement
about the Arab Spring close to two years
after things have happened it's still a
feeling of guarded optimism
it's not a piece of traditional arabic
music my records neither are traditional
Persian music or Middle Eastern music
their mix of a lot of different elements
a lot of things that I've heard and
studied I mean I am and education in
jazz I spent a lot of time playing
classical music I've played in Poppins I
mean I'm a hybridized person I'm a half
persian and half American so I'm pretty
comfortable mixing those influences
I've had a fantasy for quite some time
to have him write for the MIT Wind
Ensemble he's never composed for the
idiom of a wind ensemble a company of
woodwind brass and percussion players
and he's someone who has a kind of
artistic restraint in his temperament
that colours in a very beautiful way
everything he does in music
when you're dealing with a new piece in
front of an ensemble the first thing to
do is play it through and let them make
their statement before you have anything
to say we reworked the ending a little
bit we got to hear specifically jamshid
talking to Fred and to kind of see those
two come together was a lot of fun I
think I maybe went too far the other way
so I kinda have to bring it back but
better than the ink that's all I can say
Middle Eastern music has a lot of
quarter tones but when you're writing
for the college went ensemble you can't
expect them to learn how to play quarter
tones you know in one concert cycle he
said for him it was interesting to have
to figure out how to get that element of
the music in it the baritone sound is
just amazing to me the trumpet solos the
woodwind features they just all come
together Allah I've never really seen
the growing unquote division between the
Arts and Sciences as any kind of
dichotomy to be a complete person it
makes sense to be educated in both so
having a vibrant arts program at a
school like in my T's is important for
making complete human beings for making
human beings that connect to the world
as you know there's things that happen
in a concert that can't happen in a
rehearsal everybody brings their best
game and also as a listener as a
composer you can really let go it's just
the concert this is what it is it's just
time to enjoy it and let it flow the
first movement gives us a sense of place
which is the Middle East and as a short
section which talks about the event that
sparked the Arab Spring which was the
self-immolation of Mohamed Bouazizi and
goes on to musically illustrate how that
event led to uprisings all over the
Middle East
the second movement is a very reflective
and quiet movement in which I'm in
imagining the participants and observers
of the events of the spring just taking
stock of what has happened and
reflecting on it
and the third movement is a call to
action or a call to continue to action
you know in the hopes that what happened
the Arab Spring continues to bring
better political and human situations in
the Middle East
music is clearly one of the great
innovations of humanity passed on to us
from nature
the word awakening kind of conjures this
idea that you're coming forth with
something but yet it might not be fully
realized this power of reflection and
contemplation is so needed today and I
think that awakening in its own way
provides a vehicle for that
you